one will bring que nous amenions nos
ennemis à la justice que nous amenions
la justice à nos ennemis justice sera
faite
l'ultimatum est posée par le président
américain dix jours après les attentats
du 11 septembre le 21 septembre 2001 au
congrès les chefs militaires se tiennent
prêts à entrer en guerre avec les
talibans au pouvoir en afghanistan et
accusé de protéger al qaïda deux jours
plus tard le 23 les premières missions
de reconnaissance des buts il ya
quelques heures les etats unis ont
reconnu avoir perdu un drone un avion
espion sans pilote un type d'appareil
qui se dirige du sol et de faible
autonomie dont la présence dans le ciel
afghan accréditeraient l'hypothèse d'une
présence américaine toute proche le 6
octobre les troupes américaines s'envole
pour l'afghanistan vous êtes prêts
allez-y
rendez-nous fier on fait attention et
bonne chance à tous le lendemain le 7
octobre début de l'opération et du ring
freedom liberté immuable en français
américains et britanniques lorsqu'elle
première frappe sur les bases d'al qaïda
une cinquantaine de missiles tomahawk
tirés des bâtiments américains et
britanniques un nombre indéterminé de
bombardier les cibles une trentaine
d'objectifs sur 20 sites différents des
interprétateurs faute actuellement
l'évaluation des phrases
les bombardements continus et permettent
aux troupes américaines d'avancé celle
de l'alliance du nord progresse aussi ce
groupe armé afghan pénètre dans kaboul
13 novembre 2001 et des loges des
talibans ce n'est plus l'avant-garde
tiare
centaines de soldats juchés sur des bus
des jeeps et même quelques taxis tous
acclamé par la foule
des bataillons arrivent à pied en toute
tranquillité
après la chute de kaboul celle de
kandahar fief des talibans dans le sud
du pays les talibans ont craqué assommer
par les bombardements américains
regardez par exemple cette vidéo
diffusée par le pentagone il s'agit de
bâtiments où résidait des miliciens
intégristes un peu en dehors de la ville
16 bombes successives s'y sont abattus
la bataille de kandahar marca fin du
régime des talibans mais l'intervention
américaine va s'enliser les derniers
soldats sont partis d'afghanistan le 31
août 2021 soit presque 20 ans après le
début de la guerre laissant la place aux
talibans
[Musique]